exercise doesn't help weight loss
the reason exercise doesn't work is
because
Professor Tim Spector he's an
award-winning scientist best-selling
author and medical professor and he is
ranked in the top 100 of the world's
most cited scientists we're going to be
talking about the future of personalized
nutrition many consider you to be the
leading expert on gut health and diet
what's your view on the ketogenic diet
virtually impossible what about vitamins
waste of money what are the facts around
fasting I do oh [ __ ] what do you mean
idea the food industry wants you to
focus on calorie fat content from sugar
so you don't have to think about the
quality of the food there's never been
any long-term study showing that calorie
counting is an effective way to lose
weight and maintain weight loss this is
why I want people to think about food
very differently than we have done in
the past
so what is the cost
depression anxiety is intricately linked
to the quality of your gut microbes
these are microscopic bugs in our
intestines all of them are able to pump
out chemicals that are vital for our
body when they're fed the right Foods
the reason we're in this state is we've
killed off with all of our good bugs I
think people don't think of all the
positive members that don't think that
you need to build them up God it's so
confusing you know when you walk down
the aisle in the supermarket everything
is trying to pretend that it's good so
how do I know what is good you have to
quick one at the start of these episodes
I told you that 74 of people who watch
this channel frequently haven't yet hit
the Subscribe button and I told you that
the bigger the channel gets the better
the guests get and hopefully I've
delivered upon that for you so there's
two things I wanted to tell you the
first is if you've ever enjoyed this
channel could you do me a favor and my
team here a favor which is hit that
subscribe button because it helps this
channel more than you know and as I say
the bigger the channel the better the
guess but also we're approaching 1
million subscribers and when we hit 1
million subscribers
we've been working for many months to do
something very big in which you're all
invited to
I'll reveal that when we hit a million
subscribers
[Music]
Tim
[Music]
many consider you to be the
leading expert on topics relating to gut
health and diet and food Etc but how
would you describe your own professional
academic bio what is that bio in your
own words
it's complicated
so
I've changed form over the years quite a
lot
and I'm quite unusual in in terms of
academic medics
who usually stick very Strictly To One
specialty all their career and fear to
go anywhere else so I was a medical
school did the usual stuff then wanted
to be a physician
then did rheumatology
what's Rheumatology and bones and joints
okay so that was my sub specialty if you
like and but I got interested in
epidemiology which is the study of risk
factors in populations where you just
look at thousands of people rather than
one patient really I switched again to
study because I I got
really interested in the idea that
identical twins should be the same
they're clones they lived all their life
together
all their genes are identical
what makes them different
counter to what everyone thought
identical twins often die at different
times they get different diseases one
gets depression one's fine it's all
these differences so what that was my
sort of conundrum what makes identical
twins different
when they have the same they've lived
the same lives it was
only through this sort of search to find
this out that I looked at the gut
microbes in in Twins and found they were
different and that really scientifically
took me onto this
whole new path from there I made this so
leap into nutrition to say well now
we've discovered this whole new science
all this stuff we got wrong about
nutrition suddenly makes sense so now I
would say I'm you know an epidemiologist
who's
really
specializing in in nutrition and gut
health and trying to change the way
people think about food
that was a brilliant summary of your
career and an academic background
um as a muggle like me that's really you
know new to many of these topics what I
understand is the study of epidemiology
is the study of the like genetic root
causes of disease not just genetics so
any any exclusive disease right so the
people studying covid yeah were a
wepademologists tracking a disease
trying to work out who's getting it when
it's coming back how common it is right
all these basic things in populations at
a at a sort of big population level
right great you've also written 800
articles
more than 800 articles on this subject
matter
um in 2014 you set up the British gut
microbiome project
and you've written five books on these
subject matters I mean I've read two of
them that I sat in front of me here
um I'm really intrigued by by the
personal story as well because writing
these books and doing all the work
you've done
is a lot it's a lot of work it requires
a lot of Drive I mean this particular
book you said it took almost six years
to finish
what is the personal Drive behind that
what is driving you to pursue the
subject matter
you know I just love getting into a new
area
finding out that something that
everyone's been quoting for
decades
is total BS
and was based on some tiny study of nine
people it's like I'm a detective
and so I've always had this this quest
to sort of be this
obsessional detective I think going into
these areas and at the same time it's
that's coincided with you know various
events in my life as well that
um have probably pushed me in certain
directions more than other you know that
I wouldn't have gone otherwise what were
those events in your life
I guess you know I was pretty lazy's
um
a student at school they might surprise
some people we always assume if you're a
professor and you've made it you were a
SWOT at school but I did the absolute
minimum so I scraped into medical school
scrape through the first
few years of medical school I had spent
one year
proving you didn't have to go to any
lectures
and could still pass
which was a lot of work actually at the
end I realized it was harder then of
course age 21 my father died
suddenly overnight with a heart attack
no warning at all I was off on a skiing
holiday with some friends
and I think in retrospect that
that event
changed me and
perhaps gave me
you know a bit more
Direction and drive
than I would have had I'm not quite sure
you know how it would have turned out if
he hadn't died but to me
him dying at 57.
suddenly like that
um
made me think I I need to you know make
more of my life
I could die early too
this was something that you know I think
spurred me on to
do all this kind of stuff that I didn't
need to do but um I felt perhaps more
compulsion to do and maybe also got me
interested in this whole idea of
genetics to say well you know
did he have rotten genes
um am I have I got the same genes am I
going to die in my 50s so I think that
Looking Back Now I think
that's it's hard to be absolutely sure
but that seems uh
a reasonable scenario I read and I've
heard from members of your team that
left you with a feeling as you've kind
of said there that you might also Die
Young if it is a genetic thing
definitely yes no I was always telling
my kids you know this is this is it you
know money how many hit I was sort of
half joking but saying well you know
my times you know I've only got seven
years to go now you know whatever it is
um you were saying that two kids yes you
know that uh to try and prepare them I
guess so but it was my way of you know I
did in a jokey way it wasn't like
um I was writing my will and saying you
know
the candlesticks are here and the uh uh
everything else but it was um yeah I
used to make light of it but you know
underneath it yes I felt well
you know I could go early so I need to
get on with it I think and I was also at
that time uh price speed was sped up by
another personal incident
I had at that time
which was a mini stroke
yes I would call it a mini stroke it's a
vascular occlusion but I couldn't work
for three months I couldn't read
and I got a bit depressed about that
so those three months where you you
can't read
um
I read that you were
the quote I went from being a sporty
fitter than average middle-aged man to a
pill popping depressed stroke victim
with high blood pressure
they said you were flawed by this
experience and for three months you
couldn't work
from having a pretty fast-paced frenetic
life
to being bed bound and in those three
months you you'll focus on the
microbiome
increases right
yes I I was I was just finishing up the
very last bits of the previous book
identically different which is about why
Twins were different right
and as a sort of afterthought I had
acted one page about well actually the
microbiome could be
the key to this what is the microbiome
it's the word we use for the community
of gut microbes these are microscopic
bugs in our intestines
and it's
a biome because it's like this jungle
Community it's a lot of different
species all together thousands of them
that coexist in our in our lower
intestine our colon and they it's like
we've discovered in the last 10 years a
new organ in our bodies
if you put them all together they weigh
about the same as our brain
okay so it's that's mind-boggling really
to think about all these bugs which uh
individually are tiny putting together
they actually you know they weigh
several pounds
so you can either think of them as a
microbial Garden but increasingly I'm
shifting that towards thinking as a an
incredible Pharmacy
so all of them
are able to pump out chemicals
all the time that are vital for our body
so thousands of different chemicals are
pumped out every minute by these these
gut microbes when they're fed the right
foods and these chemicals are key for
our immune system most of our immune
system is actually in our gut
we don't most people don't know that we
think it's you know
under our armpits or somewhere but
actually
um
all the immune cells are actually
talking all the time to our gut
microbes through these chemicals and
their immune system obviously is crucial
for our whole body and fighting aging
and cancer covered infections allergies
all these kind of things so then you've
also got the microbes can produce
chemicals that affect the brain and will
make the difference between you being
happy or sad or we know that they're
vital in depression
important for regulating how much you
eat your appetite when you feel full
they also provide key vitamins for you
all the B vitamins and many other
components neurochemicals like serotonin
that's key for the happiness
and how antidepressants work are all
produced by your gut microbes so we're
slowly learning that these guys are
absolutely crucial
to how our body responds to anything
coming into it whether it's painkillers
whether it's antidepressants whether
it's chemicals in the form of food and
this is why you know I want people to
think about food very differently
than we have done in the past the idea
the old idea that food is just calories
macros you know whether it's fats and
carbs and proteins those four things you
know that's 100 years old mentality but
key to it is this this core of our gut
health which we've ignored
totally and this this was this big aha
moment for me after research for 10
years why would identical twins twins be
different
what could it be and it turns out their
gut microbes are different
that's the only thing I've ever found in
30 years that's really different about
identical twins and that explains why
one gets cancer the other one doesn't y
one gets an autoimmune disease or one's
depressed and one's happy so for me that
the twins were perfect
um
obvious way to show that how important
these these microbes are for all of us
what are some of the biggest myths you
encountered as you started researching
the microbiome that most people
currently believe that I probably sat
here now believe about how to keep my
um my gut healthy what are some of those
key myths because I know you like myth
busting
well I think most people believe that
probiotics in yogurt get killed by your
stomach acid
so they don't work because your
everything gets killed off that's a
common one I hear
but they don't no some get killed but
you're ingesting billions so always
enough get through to have an effect and
we know that probiotics do work
although the best probiotics are in food
rather than in capsules
and there's plenty of fermented foods
which is the same
I think
um
most people know very little about
microbes they think that most of them
are harmful
so oh I've you know they they cultured
this microbe or they found a parasite
fifty thousand people have now looked at
their gut microbes in the US and the UK
in the UK 24 have a parasite
and that parasite is actually beneficial
it's called blastocystis and it's
associated with good health being
thinner having less internal fat lower
blood pressure
and you know in the past we're trying to
kill it off
and actually
the reason we're in this state is we've
killed off a lot of our good bugs so I
think people need to realize that most
of the bugs in our in our system are
trying to help us
and
we've actually lost half of the good
ones compared to if you go to
hunter-gatherers or you know I spent
some time with the hadza tribe in Africa
and you know they have twice the number
of species that we have
because they don't pop antibiotics they
don't have sterile Foods they have a
very wide range of um
diverse plants Etc so I think people
uh think that you know their their gut
microbes are really only there to hurt
them when they have a bad Kebab or
something they don't think of all the
positive benefits that don't think that
you need to build them up
and that actually you know they're like
a the more you've got the better it is
how do I build them up
how do I become more like that tribe you
have to have a more diverse range of
plants
so
we did a study a few years ago with
British and American guts that showed
that if you can get up to 30 different
types of plant a week
you maximize your diversity of species
in your gut
and that's that diversity that we want
remember
30 plants you look a bit shocked but
that's um it's
a plant is a nut a seed it's not just
kale
it's a herb it's a spice
and things like coffee
are a plant to me
because it comes from a fermented Bean
so it's that diversity it's having more
fermented foods it's
having a range of colors it's cutting
out
[Music]
um
the ultra processed chemicals as well
which all that all the groups in the
population that have the best gut
microbes they don't eat the ultra
processed foods they don't have
antibiotics they don't have this this
modern Western
lifestyle you mentioned calories there
as well
um when you're talking about the
microbiome one of my friends
is a prolific calorie counter
and you know he eats a lot of Domino's
Pizzas he'll he listens to this podcast
he's going to know exactly he's going to
know that I'm ating him
um he eats Domino's Pizzas all the time
he eats like a real you know processed
food diet but then says to me it's all
about calorie counting
now with all due respect
friend
um
he's never managed to I shouldn't say
but um but it's not necessarily work for
him in terms of the goal that he set
himself so when I was reading about your
view on calorie counting in your book
spoon fed it was I screenshotted it this
morning and sent it to him and I sent I
said you are a bullshitter that's what I
said in the message and we had a good
laugh about it this morning but what is
your view on calorie counting and this
idea that we can you know weight loss or
being healthy is just about having a
calorie deficit it it's complete
nonsense yeah thank you I will clip that
and send it to him there's never been
any long-term study showing that calorie
counting is an effective way to lose
weight and maintain weight loss after
you know the first few weeks
so
yes
very strict calorie counting if you
deprive yourself for a few weeks you
will lose some weight but
even if you're successful your body's
evolutionary mechanisms will make you
hungry and hungry every week you go by
where you're depriving yourself of
energy your body will go into sort of
shutdown mode your metabolism slows down
so you're not expending those calories
and inevitably I'd say more than 95
percent of people will go back to their
Baseline and many go above it it's a
rebound back if they're doing this this
style of uh calorie restriction now
calorie counting is a part of that so
people try and say okay I'm not going
I'm not getting a dramatic diet but I'm
going to just try and Reduce by 10 my
calories in the day which in the old
theory was supposed to make you lose
weight well it's virtually impossible
even professionals to count calories
and
because
they're not very accurate for a start
everything on the packet you have to
weigh everything and in restaurants now
we're supposed to have these calorie
counts they're plus or minus about 30
percent because the portion size makes
such a huge difference to it that it it
and it's been shown in the US to be a
worthless exercise anyway
so you can't count them going in you
can't really count your metabolism going
out either we're all incredibly
different you know your friends probably
been told 2500 calories is what he's
allowed
well that's an average
uh but it doesn't mean it relates to him
my average is much lower and when I
tested it so everyone is an individual
and this is another thing we need to
move away from this one-size-fits-all
guidelines but I think more importantly
is that
the whole calorie counting assumption
means that it doesn't matter what form
that calorie is it has the same effect
in your body therefore whether you're
cutting out fat calories or carb
calories or you know low calorie
sodas or whatever it is it's it's going
to be fine but we now know that's not
true
and there's several science experiments
which now absolutely nail that
one was
um but in America where they gave people
identical meals
um for two weeks in a sort of enclosed
semi-prison and one was homemade and one
was Ultra processed both identical
calories macros the same
the group of the ultra processed foods
over at by about 200 calories every day
they kept came back to the buffet for
more okay so
yes the same calories but the effect on
the body meant they were hungrier why is
that
we don't know for sure it could be
that those chemicals in the ultra versus
Foods affect the gut microbes
and they then send signals to the brain
saying eat more this isn't a natural you
know this is a really weird chemical
it's doing something weird to me I'm
producing something weird in exchange
it could be they get absorbed much
quicker
so you get a big sugar rush and you know
the nutrients get in to your body in a
way faster than they should do in nature
and so your brain doesn't have time to
say I'm full it normally takes 20
minutes or so to to get that fullness
um or you know it so it could be the
Matrix of the food it could be the
chemicals in the food it could be its
effect on the gut microbes
um but it also could be
things like your sugar spikes so in the
Zoe predict studies where basically
we've given Now 50 000 people
um in the US and the UK the same Foods
at the same time
same time of day everyone's got these
muffins we show that people
um one in four people who have these
muffins and are wearing it we wear
glucose monitors which tells you for two
weeks of what's happening in your
glucose one in four people get a real
sugar dip
three hours later so this is where you
you rise in Sugar which is normal and
then as it comes down it goes below
Baseline
but only in one in four people
and when that happens those people end
up uh overeating the next meal and
during the day they feel more tired more
hungry that's this the sort of 11
o'clock slump if you like if you've had
a carbi breakfast some people feel that
others don't
and what's really interesting is that so
one in four people eating an identical
muffin of identical calories will then
overeat by this you know another 10 that
day
so you can see how that just blows the
calorie
idea out that the calories in equals
calories out everything's the same and
and the third thing is that Ultra
processed food says it has the calories
that's equal to the Whole Foods but
often they don't account for the fact
that it's ground up it's highly refined
and so if you take like almonds or
something like this these might use
ground almonds and you compare ground
almonds to whole almonds
there's perhaps 30 percent less
available calories and the whole almonds
than there is in the other one so the
whole thing is a complete nonsense and
it's there
because the food industry wants you to
focus on the calorie
the fat content
sugar so you don't have to think about
the quality of the food
and it's something that they can control
very easily get their profits higher
keep adding stuff to the product that's
synthetic
when we know that a lot of things are
adding are harmful for our gut microbes
so that the artificial sweeteners are
harmful the the glues they stick the
foods together the emulsifiers some
people react quite a lot to those and
they cause problems so the whole thing
is like this giant camouflage
and that's
that's really one thing I'm you know it
might probably my number one bug bear is
to
get people to see the light
stop obsessing about calories and start
thinking about food much more as quality
and what it does to your body
quality food what is quality food in
your definition of the phrase it's the
opposite of ultra processed food which
is Whole Food which is made with
from the original ingredients of plants
mainly plant-based but it's not
exclusively that
contains all the nutrients that those
those plants produce without it being
Stripped Away or
boiled up or highly pressurized
deformed and so they have to add in back
those nutrients so you know it's things
in their pure form so it's
it's nuts it's seeds it's it's grains
that haven't been ground up super finely
it's all the amazing plants and fruits
and vegetables that we've got
they they're healthy foods but you know
it's it's not straightforward yes I've
got this list of 10 superfoods it's it's
understanding that many foods that
you know are healthy for us most of them
are in their in their original form
berries nuts
um
virtually every vegetable
is healthy for us if it's in that
original form it's only because we've we
had to learn to preserve things we had
to
do trickery to make you know margarines
and things with chemistry that we've
moved away from that but
you know going back you know
olive oil for example is a great example
of saying that the vilified often
because it has lots of fats in it and
you know sending I was done oh the med
trains they have they have olive oil and
everything it's horrible it's all fatty
turns out that's that's a perf you know
it comes from the olive
the good stuff extra virgin olive oil
has very little done to it and that is a
a good healthy quality food but
it can be refined you can take that and
you can keep refining it
um you can take corn on the cob as an
example and then you you know and then
you've got I don't know uh
tortilla chips or something down the
other end is which Bears or cornflakes
which Bears no resemblance
to the original and they're all versions
on the Spectrum
God it's so confusing you know because
what you've said to me is
you know based on research and studies
but then when I go to a supermarket
labeling even I just thinking in
cornflakes I think I grew up thinking
conflicts were healthy because it says
corn in the title you know what I mean
and it's and when you're trying to
navigate I was just thinking if I'm
going down an aisle now hearing what
you've just said that that quality food
is food that is not Ultra processed and
kind of resembles its original form
when you walk down the aisle in the
supermarket everything is trying to
pretend that it's good
so how do I know what is good I mean I
can go to the vegetable aisle and I can
say okay that looks like a cabbage it
looks like no one's messed with that
there's been no study done on that to it
hasn't been through a laboratory but how
do I like if I'm in an aisle tomorrow
how do I know what food is good and what
is not well you've said the first thing
if it's not in a package
um you're pretty sure it's good okay so
um
if it's concealed in some package that's
got you know happy children and signals
of vitamins in it that should be a
warning sign you know the more they have
to advertise the food and say what its
additives are and everything the more
you should be wary about it the number
of ingredients is another pretty good
sign so once you get over 10
particularly if there's lots you've
never heard of you wouldn't find in your
kitchen you should also be wary that
that is ultra processed food anything
that says low calorie that says means
they've had to add in lots of artificial
sweeteners or protein extracts or
something else is also a big danger sign
low in fat means they've replaced the
natural fat with something else that's
cheaper and these are all warning signs
you know
and you know you take breakfast cereals
I mean I used to
I used to eat lots of breakfast cereals
I was brought up on them highly sugary
stuff and then I thought I was being
healthy when I moved to muesli's and um
posha stuff
uh but actually when you still you know
that appearance of healthiness it's
still got lots of additives in it it's
still got lots of sugar in it it's just
and
those cereal packets have added vitamins
in it but they're often in a very poor
form
I did an experiment once where I
um took some cornflakes or special care
I can't remember that said had added
iron and if you mix it up you can put a
magnet on it you can get off the iron
filings they're so cheap that they just
added to tick a box saying it has iron
but they don't get into your body or do
anything so anything that's got
these things added with this in it low
in this is a sign that they're obscuring
the quality of the product so it's
you know but there's a lot of brain you
know we've been brainwashed for years
and decades in this and you know I was
as well as a doctor
you know I should know better
and yet I've completely changed my
Sev two of my meals completely so I've
gone from having muesli with low-fat
milk and an orange juice and uh a cup of
tea
because I I did you know I started doing
these tests for Zoe I found out that
gave me a massive sugar Spike
and it was a terrible way to start the
day and I got these you know dips at 11
o'clock to a High full fat yogurt nuts
seeds a few berries and never have
orange juice that's on my that's a
really unhealthy drink for everybody
and I have a lots of black coffee which
I now know is good for me so
that's totally different I changed my
lunch
for at least 10 15 years
um when I got in the hospital I was
having a hospital lunch which
used to be in the canteen then it was
the Marks and Spencers got a healthy
looking sandwich with brown bread sweet
corn
and tuna and a smoothie in a little
bottle
and
that gave a massive sugar Spike and I
wouldn't have known that
and I was told that should have been a
healthy thing to eat so
you know there's there's general rules
but also there are specific rules and
this whole idea of individual
individuality is coming in so it could
be that you could you might be fine on
that don't know
um I was very annoyed because
when I started we were starting doing
this testing for Zoe I had all these
spare kits and I gave my wife one as
well
and we sit down and
she's
French Belgian and loves croissants and
so we'd have croissant each mine would
shoot up she had no change at all in her
her sugar which is really annoying yeah
so but it also brings brings home the
fact that you know
everyone loves simplistic rules
but you can only get so far
with them you have to start
experimenting yourself and see what
works for you and not just take
everything for granted and that's really
the
that's the whole essence of really you
know setting up this personalized
nutrition research and Zoe and
everything else but uh
on top of this general advice about
changing our idea of food I think
because I think they do go hand in hand
that if you realize there are these
individual differences you realize it's
not as simple as you've been told it's
not that fats are evil it's not that
calories are bad you know it's it's much
more nuanced
you mentioned breakfast there I heard
that you do some intermittent fasting
intermittent fasting I think I
pronounced that correctly intermittent
fasting yes we'll just uh use AI to swap
that for my voice
what is it intermittent let's just call
it fasting just for people at home that
can't say it
um
fasting has become a really popular
thing over the last three or four years
A lot of my friends talk about it again
it's it's almost feels like it's going
into fad territory again but what is the
what are the facts around fasting
intermittently
okay it's
I guess it's been quite a Hot Topic
about 10 years now but it's intermittent
fasting so umbrella term for all kinds
of different fasting and you might
remember the five two style of
intermittent fasting was quite big about
10 years ago and there were also these
extended fasts often used in America
people doing two or three day
fasts and detoxifying oh gosh yeah that
sort of stuff so you've got to realize
you have to specify what time what what
we're talking about but I think the most
interesting type of fasting now is
what's called time restricted eating
time restricted eating I can say that
Tre okay so the idea is you don't change
what you eat you just change how you eat
and you change your eating window so
most people in in the UK and U.S they'll
be eating for 14 or 16 hours a day it's
me right lots of snacks and extending
late night and
what time strict eating is you're trying
to reduce that to something like 10
hours
on average okay it varies there are some
more extreme ones some milder ones but
that seems about The Sweet Spot that
most people can manage 10 hours which
means uh you start eating at 11 and you
finish at nine for example or you might
want to go from eight in the morning
until six at night oh seven I can't do
my maths
um
now there's actually science behind this
now so there's plenty of studies showing
that not only in mice and rats this
helps them their metabolism their energy
management but
there's some evidence that helps with
weight loss
to a small extent but it's it improves
your inflammation levels and a lot of
people report energy and mood
improvements we've just done a big study
with the Zoe health study which is the
the free app where we had 130 000 people
sign up to do this trial if you like
where they would do this for two weeks
and amazingly most people Managed IT and
we did see improvements in mood and
energy
um just in that two-week period and
actually hunger went down weirdly but a
lot of this we've found is people are
actually snacking less so they weren't
we won't tell them to do less you just
you can do whatever you like in that
time but people are just paying more
attention and not grabbing something to
eat just before they went to bed now the
science behind it's really interesting
because your body needs time to recover
so your cells
we're programmed on the Circadian rhythm
that is very much in in line with the
Sun from you know when we were in East
Africa and it was
um
everything was quite programmed so that
our body is in this state of work during
the day we eat do all our stuff and then
at night it recovers as the stress
hormones go down then you repair stuff
comes out so cleans up all the muck in
ourselves but we now know that it's the
same happening in our guts so if you
rest your gut for 14 hours you give time
for all the other microbes to come out
and act as a repair team like a cleaning
force that Hoover up all the mess you've
left behind they clean up nicely your
gut wall and so it's not leaky get rid
of inflammation and this change giving
them a break really seems to have these
great benefits so I'm I was a real
skeptic about about this and I did lots
of fasting and things for experimenting
the books but it I think the last two
years I've really been convinced that
this is
something that that does work and
is right for some people but importantly
it's not right for everybody and there
is an individuality you may be a snacker
that finds it very hard to go long
periods of time without eating okay I do
know we've got several people at Zoe who
say oh this is terrible you know so but
for me you know I suddenly realized when
I wake up in the morning I'm not
starving
it's not the first thing I I think in my
head and it's very easy to wait till 11
o'clock to have something to eat and
it's not a big deprivation that's
something you could carry on the whole
of your life which I think is what we're
we're into here so I think there's a lot
to be said for this but I think people
need to personalize it
again you know people love a single
single black and white solution to all
their problems but I'd say to everyone
try it you may want to you know do a
sort of American style eating really
early and finishing early
um you might be that kind of person
who's also morning person or you might
be someone that prefers the social life
of eating in the evening and um
skipping the morning it's going to be
it's going to be take quite a lot of
discipline for me to stop having
chocolate at 2AM so could you just
summarize again time restricted eating
the the key benefits of it are my
microbiome will be healthier gives my
microbiome more time to clean up which
will have an impact potentially on
weight loss and overall energy levels
etc etc mood okay cool that's enough for
me I think that's a convincing enough
reason and I imagine there's also an
impact on sleep there because you know
me having chocolate at 2am
is probably not going to give um help me
have quality sleep at night
absolutely yes no I think there is a
link we're studying that we don't have
any results from from that trial but we
are logging Sleep Quality as well but
personally I've I've when I've started
to do it I do sleep better I did start
to get some reflux as well so a lot of
people suffer from heartburn right and
and that's again because you're eating
and drinking alcohol quite late they're
not leaving enough time to go to bed
that causes sort of stress on your body
when it's supposed to be relaxing so I
think yeah everyone give that you know
give that a try and you know it could be
right for you and it just makes you
think also
you're just thinking about more what
you're eating you know to say okay let's
give my body a rest just like you would
if you're doing an exercise regime
whatever it's just thinking about eating
in a different way other than just fuel
what about vitamins
you know I've I've got all these
vitamins by my bedside not by my bedside
by my by my bathroom sink in my bedroom
because you know I went I went to some
market and the lady there told me that
all these vitamins are important and
then I don't know I'm actually an ad on
Facebook or something and I ended up
buying more vitamins and I'm like a
collector of vitamins
we're not alone I think 50 of the
British population have a regular
vitamin or supplement every day and it's
massive industry I read chapter five of
your book so I'm a bit rude about
vitamins in there please please so I
know and I it's the thing that upsets
people most
um people say I don't I believe
everything else you say but I don't
believe your chapter on on vitamins and
I again it's it's a bit like a religion
you know popping a pill and uh hoping
that it's doing some good all the
evidence shows that
when you do a randomized controlled
trial these vitamins don't work
unless you've got some really weird
disease or deficiency or for some reason
you can't eat a normal diet but it's a
last resort for people who have terrible
diets if you have a a decent varied diet
with plenty of plants in it you don't
need
vitamins at all
and I used to take them and I don't take
any now except the occasional B12
because I
um I've always been low in B12 and I
have hardly any meat
but apart from B12
all the evidence points to these things
being a complete waste of money
you're telling me all those vitamins
I've swallowed over the last 10 years
have been
a
the result of me being duped by the
vitamin industry and have no material
impact on my health
yes well they might have had some
harmful effects like people taking
calcium and things like this are showing
if you take regular calcium tablets more
likely to get heart disease you're
joking I've literally got a tub of
calcium Tablets by my by my kitchen sink
as we speak yeah well there's calcium in
nearly every plant and things that we we
normally break down absorb in small
amounts regularly you take something
like a calcium supplement you might be
taking half a gram of it
our body isn't designed to break down
that huge slab of chemical and so it
doesn't get distributed well and studies
show that it gets deposited in your
arteries and and can Harden them up so
there's no there's no evidence that
calcium helps people doesn't help broken
bones it doesn't help osteoporosis all
the things that we were told it did do
so all the elements was out there and
you've got all these companies pushing
it so many of these things can be
counterproductive but my main worry
about them is if people think
they can pop a pill they don't have to
think about
proper food yeah and therefore
everything can comes in a bottle or a
pill they can go you know just have a
junk food diet and be healthy and that's
so wrong because diet I think is the
most
as I said the most important food
choices we make for our health and to
take stuff that doesn't work that could
be counterproductive and sometimes
harmful is is a Daft delusion
I have been under a dark delusion I've
got so many supplements upstairs well
they could have a placebo effect you
might feel better because you've taken
them you know you think I feel like a
healthy person because I take them I
don't know whether I am a healthy person
but I feel like one when I do it I do it
and it's really uncomfortable because
I'm taking sometimes I'm taking like
eight different pills like calcium and
potassium and whatever else em and when
I'm doing it even though it's hard to
swallow them and it tastes rancid I feel
like I'm doing future Steve a favor yeah
well there you go but clearly I have to
get someone to make you some dummy ones
so there's got nothing harmful in it and
you can take it a lot cheaper I'll give
that a shot
um what about sugar so I I was keto for
the last roughly the last two months I
tried
um the diet because I had a lot of good
things about the ketogenic diet as it
relates to an inflammation
and I have to be honest I lost about a
stone in weight fairly quickly first
time I've really seen a huge dip in my
weight but also not just that my the gut
issues that I'd had seemed to
to go so I I'd almost lived for the last
couple of years specifically like after
the age of 25 for some reason suddenly
foods that I thought had gluten in them
like white breads and pastas and even
like soy sauce and things like that were
making me live in this permanent state
of like being bloated and I'd go to the
toilet and I didn't feel great it was
kind of this pain throughout the day a
couple of hours after eating one of
those foods and then I tried the
ketogenic diet so I cut out pretty much
all of those things like I didn't have
any bread
most of the sort of processed bad carb I
don't even know what I'm talking about
here so correct me but I cut out what I
thought were the bad carbs that were
having a bad reaction on me and then I
cut out a lot of sugar like refined
sugars basically cut it completely out
and I ate meat vegetables
um berries and things like that
felt fantastic
lost a stone in weight
very very very lean body fat dropped
completely slept well high energy
um what's your view on the ketogenic
diet
well your story is I mean you can take
two ways one you could say you really
improved your diet because you had it
sounds like you had a pretty shitty Diet
before that right so yeah
um so you know what I mean so anything
could have been an improvement if
someone says if you're eating real foods
right so yeah it sounds like the keto
you weren't having keto out of a bottle
or a plastic and I was having meals yeah
proper home-cooked meals rather than
takeaways and exactly so you're making
the shift from perhaps you know the
average UK diet which is high in refined
carbs which is you know probably had a
fair bit of ultra processed foods in
there as well to this other diet so I
would expect you to feel better
um to be a keto diet you've got to get
to sit about 70
um fat right which yeah which is really
really hard for anyone to to sustain
it's virtually impossible that's why I
said for the last two months I'm no
longer keep on the keto diet so you know
you've you've gone you've so you have
probably done a mild keto diet right
that didn't put you into ketosis right
but got you off these high refined carbs
yeah so
but going back to the basic question
um keto diets do seem to work for people
with diabetes who are overweight as a
way of getting them off their
medications and sort of kick-starting
them into a better health pattern and
there are some people I think it can
work for
um I think for as a sustainable diet I
don't think it makes any sense I don't
think many people can still be on it a
year later if it's a true ketogenic diet
because
no Studies have really shown that people
can sustain eating that level of fat and
protein and virtually no carbs that's
all I ate for about eight weeks yeah but
you were eating you're eating plants as
well
um so I'd have like some plants wasn't
just steak was it it was I mean at one
point it felt like that it was there was
some plants in there there was like
lettuce and broccolis and stuff like
that but I was Googling everything to
check if it was keto friendly before I
put it in my mouth so yeah I mean so I
think what interesting is if you you
went from that to a more uh mixed
healthy gut-friendly diet
you know which includes fermented foods
small amounts of breads grains Etc
um I think you'd still find the same
benefits because you're shifting from
Ultra you know because I would suspect
that if you did the Zoe test for example
you would have quite a big reaction to
sugars and your fat control would be
quite good
so it sounds like you tolerate quite
large amounts of fat without too much
problem whereas the sugars would spike
like me you get a reaction you get
Hunger you get you know
these feelings of tiredness Etc so just
by upping your fat levels lowering your
refined carb levels you might have
produced the same without doing that
extreme idea because my problem with the
keto diets is ultimately it's
restrictive
you're reducing the number of foods
you're thinking about your uh
ultimately then harming your gut
microbes long term because you're not
giving them the variety of different
plants if you're not careful and that
happens to a lot of people they go down
any of these slightly fatty diets and
they end up with a much more restrictive
um
you know intakes than they would have
done which long term will cause some
problems for their immune health and
long-term health so that's why I'm
generally against these extreme diets of
any kind other than if you are you know
seriously ill diabetic and you're
overweight it for three months it could
be a really good way to get you off your
meds
interesting
yeah because I'm trying to I'm trying to
find now so I went from the keto diet to
the New York diet basically we went to
New York for two weeks and I just I
really [ __ ] up
um but now I'm back I'm trying to find
the nice Middle Ground the sustainable
middle ground that word sustainability
in my diet and also my fitness has been
key to me
um because if I can't sustain it there's
no point doing it because you end up
yoyoing afterwards so I went from the
keto diet as I said to the New York diet
and now I'm back in in the in the UK so
we'll go on the gut friendly diet which
is please detail the gut-friendly diet
just it's you know 30 different plants a
week
lots of fermented foods that's your
yogurts your kefirs your kombuchas and
if you like kimchi kraut
uh miso Koji Japanese food
eating the rainbow so you've got plenty
of colors on your plate everything's got
because that means they've you've got
plants there that have got these defense
chemicals and we haven't talked about
these but these are the polyphenols that
are in plants that give them that bitter
taste but also the bright colors that
you get in berries and you get in bright
colored lettuce and cabbages and
they are rocket fuel for your gut
microbes so the more you've got of those
the healthier your gut the more you
dampen down inflammation so really
important there's most diversity lots of
color and lots of high polyphenol Foods
things you wouldn't have thought are
healthy so dark chocolate I know you
like doctor was it well I'm not sure is
it milk chocolate you have it yeah it's
milk chocolate well you need to change
the dark chocolate my girlfriend says
that she's obsessed with dark chocolate
well and she always tells me take her
lead it's slowly slowly wean yourself
off the milk and get onto real chocolate
okay which actually tastes of
Sun really good rather than sugar isn't
white chocolate the worst yes do you
know how I know that that's the only
thing I know about food um I went and
did a chocolate making class and at the
start of the class the instructor says
pour the sugar into where these big
tubes and she said pour the sugar into
the tube so I'd like pulled a bit in she
was like no no no no
fill that tube with 60 sugar
I was like what she was like fill the
tube with I was like why she goes that's
white chocolate it's 60 sugar so I pour
this this sugar into this tube and it
fills at 60 and then I put this little
like oily liquid in and she was mix it
because that's white chocolate 60 sugar
there's people right now that are sat
there eating it would realize that
they're giving themselves early on to
diabetes but so dark chocolate is a good
example coffee we already mentioned and
if you like coffee I do I well I don't
for me coffee is more of a utility
I use it before I have these
conversations so I don't fall asleep
because I'm very you know I've never
been good boring guest well sometimes
but it's more so just to try and keep my
mind sharp and to keep focused but um I
I've read chapter 13 of your book about
coffee and I've always been a bit of a
coffee skeptic because I tend to have a
belief that everything in life comes
with a cost and no one I've sat here
with has ever been able to tell me the
cost of an artificial boost in my focus
attention energy I feel like nothing's
for free in life you know
so what is the cost of coffee
well I think there's a variability some
people there is a big cost they get the
shakes they can't sleep and it has other
neurotoxic effects if you have too much
so I think it's all about dose
and this is
it is a drug that if you get the dose
right
is very beneficial for you if you get it
wrong or you've got some genetic problem
you can't process it right it it's a
real it's it's a problem but some of the
benefits I was talking about
um are also there in decaffeinated
coffee
so it also has these because again it's
a great example of how we always think
of coffee as caffeine right and yet if
you do these epidemiology studies you
know these big population ones people
who are having regular decaf coffee also
have similar heart benefits so it's
other things in this fermented Bean that
are helping us and I think this is just
you know it's a great lesson moving away
from our reductionism we always like to
think of you know one food is one
vitamin or one chemical and that's an
easy way to think about it we can't
comprehend they've got a thousand
different
ingredients so decaf coffee but yeah
well you've got green tea is also pretty
good
um you know there's many other fermented
foods but um the polyphenols are really
good and important to realize in the
book food for life I go into
exactly that it's a practical guide to
when you go into the supermarket and you
go to the aisle so gosh I'm in the
vegetable oil do I get my usual iceberg
lettuce that
90 of us do
because it lasts for two weeks or you
know longer than our Prime Ministers or
do we go for a slightly more expensive
loose leaf rossololo with purple leaves
that has a thousand times more
polyphenols
and so you really shop on color
yes now I do I had no idea about this
until do you but but also the fact is
loose leaved means that those those
plants have had to survive in more
difficult conditions to fight off
predators and wind and everything else
so they're tougher that's why herbs and
spices are also tough because they're
the growing tips
of the plant that's where you get all
the good bits and so it's a rethinking
all this idea about what's good about
food in this when you start thinking
about your gut and you know the sugars
that it releases Etc so
um for you yeah I mean if I think it's a
general rule if everybody
at to keep their gut microbes happy
they'd be on a pretty healthy diet even
before you get into personalization
now chapter 13 of your book we talked
about coffee there is called coffee can
save your life
you mean that quite literally don't you
yes as an epidemiologist
if you drink three cups of coffee a day
you are less likely to die 10 years
later Jesus Christ but there's also a
link between um coffee depression and
suicide right
well there are lots of links
because I was reading that in studies
people were less suicidal if they'd been
drinking coffee
um
I think
that I'm sure there is a study on that
in general what I what I do when I look
at these is I don't take any one study
on its own I'll try to get
uh look at all the literature and say
how many studies there are in that and
is there a a confirmatory one that would
make it real or not so I've tried not to
over claim yeah because if you look at
you know
you look at the daily mail or you know
the general press in the UK they will
pick up on any one story and say coffee
gives you cancer coffee does this coffee
gives a dementia next year you know it
saves your life it does this so you can
switch
but what I think people need to do is
you know especially after covert has be
much more sort of selective about how
they see us study it's epidemiology that
it has to have confirmatory data so I
think yeah coffee we know improves
sports performance by one percent right
so for most people
that doesn't really matter right you
know one percent am I going to run
faster on my treadmill at the gym by one
percent no but it it does give you a
little bit of focus and uh for most
people it it's it you know it's a good
drug that's found in food and I like
coffee because also it helps it's
allowed in a fast so time restricted
eating
you allowed black coffee and black tea
and it um because it doesn't cause a
sugar Spike or anything else but it's
you have to cut out the sugar
a quick one from our longest standing
sponsor hero I I can't tell you over the
last I'd say over the last really it's
been about two and a half years it was
really um post pandemic how much my
health has become such a huge priority
in my life huel has been probably the
most important partner in my health
Journey because
I've been in the boardrooms I've been to
their offices
tens and tens and tens and tens of times
I've seen how they make their decisions
on nutrition and that's why it's such a
wonderful thing to be able to talk to
this audience about a brand and a
product that is so unbelievably linked
to my values and the place I am in my
life are valuing the gym exercise
movement my mind my breathing and all of
those things and most importantly my
nutrition that is the role fuel plays
and so every time I get to read these
ads out I do it with such passion
because I really really believe every
word I'm saying and I absolutely love
the brand so if you haven't already
tried heal and you've been resistant to
my my pestering then give it a go and
let me know how you get on quick one
Intel one of our podcast sponsors and I
want to talk to you for a second about
their built for business vpro platform
in today's Working World the office is
pretty much anywhere and Intel V Pro
means you can remotely manage repair and
protect devices across your entire
organization no matter how large or
small giving me and my team peace of
mind to work wherever we choose to for
my it team whether on premise or a cloud
behind the corporate firewall or not
Intel's vpro comprehensive manageability
has us covered this is something that is
so important to me I you know I'm a huge
believer in employee flexibility and
Trust so having features like this are
super helpful so to find out more search
intel.co.uk vpro and let me know how you
get on
it's like more and more people are
becoming gluten intolerant
I consider myself one of them I am a
self-diagnosed gluten intolerant
I read chapter 16 of your book and you
think most of that is made up
yes
um most people think they're gluten
intolerant aren't when you test them
okay so that's that's the fact it
doesn't mean that
everyone's making it up some of those
will be real
but I think gluten got this bad rap
about 10 years ago and there's we know
that yes one percent of the population
really do have a gluten problem it's
called celiac disease and they'll be
vomiting and have terrible diarrhea with
a smallest bit of gluten then this is
how other group of people that believe
they have gluten intolerance of which
studies show about
three quarters when they're tested with
gluten are fine
in a blind blinded way if someone
slipped you a biscuit or something you
know or pasta is often the way to trick
people and I think many people
have
probably a more General irritable bowel
syndrome
that that are blaming gluten because
it's one they're taking that one protein
that they know about from foods that
have thousands of them and saying this
is the problem
again this reductionism and it then they
cut everything out but they might be
cutting out things that were like the
sandwich for example that was causing me
glucose spikes so they might feel better
when they cut that out and they then say
okay I've cut out bread therefore
um I'm not getting sugar spikes and
tiredness that must have been the gluten
but actually it was nothing to do with
that it's just
um cheap bread
that has nothing to do with it so I
think often people are taking clues in
this excuse and sometimes they do feel
better when they cut out all this Foods
because they're eating less
processed foods as a result of it not
always but it's something else in the
bread or the pasta that that they were
eating too much or they were eating too
fast or these things that I think are
important so I would urge everyone to
you know look again at where there is
gluten or it is something else about
their food habits before that was bad
and reevaluate it and you know build up
your plant
diversity and your gut microbes instead
because the worry is that all these
people on on gluten most of them have a
rather restrictive diet they get very
worried about new foods and that's like
the worst scenario because you end up on
a vicious circle where you you get more
and more nervous so you have a smaller
and smaller group of foods you're happy
with yeah your microbes get
diminished and you have much less
flexibility to deal with any new food
that hits you
one of the um we've got a fitness group
amongst some of my friends is about 10
of us in it and um we've been tracking
how often we work out and how frequently
we work out in the workouts that we do
and one of the things I have to say is
pretty much no one in the group has lost
any weight we've been doing this for a
year
and uh that kind of bucks what you would
think so the only time that I lost
weight was actually when I went on the
keto keto diet I went from 14 Stone 8 to
13 stone 8 in roughly in several weeks
but exercise and exercising for almost
religiously for the last two and a half
years doesn't really seem to impact my
weight at all in a you know in the way
that the
Fitness Experts might tell me on
Instagram
what's your stance on the rollback
exercise plays in weight loss
has very little role in weight loss all
the studies such long-term studies show
uh it doesn't help uh weight loss
and it's been grossly exaggerated as an
easy fix for our obesity problem
exercise doesn't help weight loss no
all the studies show that the only
caveat to that is if you have changed
your diet improved your diet and you've
lost some weight
at maintaining some exercise does help
prevent it going back up again but as on
its own if you don't change your diet
it's of no use and that's
well known Now by all the bestie experts
and all the studies this shouldn't make
us fat is that the culprit
is that one of the main things that's
contributing to no again that's that's
reductionism you know we the
but the reason there is an exercise
doesn't work it's important to realize
this is because
we all know this that you know you go
for a walk build up Hunger
before a meal that's what your parents
told you you know and everything about
exercise is after it your body slows
down your metabolism slows down and it
tries to regain the energy that you've
lost that's just what our Evolution and
so that's why it's a
you're not gonna it's great for your
health and I exercise
fantastic for your mood it's great for
your heart anti-cancer all kinds of
things we should all do it but
absolutely not if your goal is weight
loss you have to do something about
changing your diet and I think that's
that's the big a huge myth particularly
perpetuated by gyms and fitness apps and
everything else and it is complete
nonsense I read that you um when you
look to studies over 30 years and you
looked at how many studies had been done
on the relationship of exercise and
weight versus
things like sugar and weight there was
12 more 12 times more studies done on
the relationship of exercise and weight
versus sugar and weight and why why is
that
why is there less research done on the
latter
um I think that's the influence of
governments and the food companies and
the drink companies
so
a lot of the exercise
research done in the last 20 years was
sponsored by large corporations
who wanted to make this link between uh
exercise and weight loss so that they
could continue to sell sugary Ultra
processed foods and drinks and just say
it's the childhood obesity is because
we've we don't have playgrounds and we
don't encourage this and that's why the
Cokes and the Pepsis are always there at
the Olympic sponsoring Olympic events
and associating themselves with Sport
and they gave
hundreds of millions to various
physiology departments Sports
departments nutrition departments to do
research in this area basically it was
really hard to get anyone to do research
into how sugary drinks make you gain
weight or cause problems because they
the amount of money for nutrition has
been abysmally poor you know in from
from governments and that's why you know
we the only the first ever study of
ultra processed food in a controlled
trial was only about three years ago and
it's been around for you know 30 40
years so such is the power of that Lobby
that it it doesn't
necessarily distort the research in a
sort of you know evil way but they
point it to make sure that the
researchers are working in an area that
they want uh people to work in and
distracting them keeping away from
talking about sugars or even artificial
sweeteners which in my view are nearly
as bad because they're sort of
you know hidden
and deflecting us from the idea that yes
giving kids sugary drinks or even
artificial sweet drinks is going to be
bad for them and cause obesity wait so
I'm I've been I've cut my I cut out
sugary drinks
about a year ago
I still have the same Brands but I have
the no sugar version oh dear oh [ __ ]
what do you mean idea
well all the all the summary of the
trials shows that if you take
a young yard out young adults and kids
and they will say on two cans of you
know
full sugar sodas and you change into the
diet version
there's no real difference in in weight
or metabolic
changes in their blood
you will go to the dentist less
so you don't get as many fillings but
and yet you know you should be gaining
300 calories right if you were doing two
cans a day
so it doesn't work out as it should do
and that's because of the extra these
chemicals are not inert
so the sweeteners in kids they changed
their their brains to give them
they want more sweetness in their food
okay so it it could reflect your wish
for your your late night milk chocolate
who knows
um and it it makes it very difficult to
train kids to have more bitter Foods or
sour Foods if they've got these
artificial sweeteners in their diet all
the time but
they've now shown that all these
sweeteners actually affect your gut
microbes
so even Stevia you know these sort of
so-called healthy ones have an effect on
your gut microbes and they're not inert
so we know that saccharin and Sucralose
also cause spikes in your blood sugar
when I did it you know I have a Trace
they're not supposed to but they they
actually do things they're not supposed
to so we know very little about these
these products and my view is that they
are harmful probably not as bad as
having the sugar but they are absolutely
not a health
drink and we should be encouraging
people to have you know teas and
kombuchas and uh more more bitter
tasting interesting flavors and Foods
than just this Ultra sweet
uh chemical concoctions is this this
sugar conglomerate that I've been
funding much of the research that points
towards
um some of the things you're talking
about there
there that's also the conglomerate that
wants us to believe the calories in
calories out approach because
if I just view every all foods as kind
of equal and on this sort of calorie
number then I can drink some of the
sugary fizzy drinks and some of the
processed foods as long as I keep it
within that sort of calorie deficit I'll
be fine and so are they is that Sugar
conglomerate is the processed food
conglomerate
for the calorie model absolutely they
need that right they absolutely it's
vital you know zero calories or one
calorie you know on the can that's what
you see and you know you're fooling
people into thinking this is a healthy
drink and oh you know if I used to have
full Coke or Pepsi are now having the
diet version I'm getting 300 calories
less a day I should lose weight it's
exactly what they've been doing and
they're also desperate to show that
artificial sweeteners are
really healthy and they come down on
anyone who tries to say that they're you
know could be any way dangerous and yet
they're not obliged to test them
so none of it none of the chemicals
added
really go through rigorous testing on
how they affect our gut microbes and
this is
this you know their testing mechanisms
haven't changed in 50 years the gut
microbiome
um the microbiome as an organ one of the
things you talked about earlier was the
impact it has on mood
and you know this podcast is was started
as kind of a business podcast we have a
lot of people that are interested in you
know being more productive being more
successful reaching for their goals
how significant and how pertinent is the
microbiome on my performance as an
entrepreneur as a business person what
do I need to know about the relationship
as it relates to my mood my performance
my mind
well we know more about mood than
than anything else
um and so we do know that depression
anxiety is intricately linked to the
quality of your gut microbes
we know this from Mouse studies where
they've
transplanted uh poo from anxious mice
into sterile mice and those new mice
then become anxious and depressed really
so it's a transmissible condition and if
you go back to me telling you that one
of the chemicals that our microbes
produce is serotonin okay some sort of
cuddle you know love
friendly warm
um chemical that affects our brain that
you know is the key to dopamine and
everything else that goes on in our head
so
the levels of that are really important
for us having the right neurochemical
balance in our head that stops us
getting very depressed or very anxious
so we know that you can transmit it
between animals so when they say they
take the Poo out of one Mouse they put
it inside its gut inside its stomach to
give it the same microbiome makeup
inside its stomach yeah and then that
mask will become depressed and anxious
yes so a lot of the science behind
microbiome is based on
large-scale human studies where you've
just got
cross-sectional data or this is
associated with this but you don't know
if it's cause or effect and so there's
this whole other group that's been going
off of of of projects for 30 years where
they have these sterile mice
who have no microbes and you you create
in a lab these other microbes that you
would make them anxious or they're
genetically anxious you look at their
microbes and you put
take their microbes you put them into
the sterile mice and you can change
their mood and their attention span and
everything else about that so that that
shows that these have a direct effect
rather than just being secondary and
that it links to the human data that
shows if you take a groups of depressed
or anxious people you
virtually all of them will have a
deranged microbiomes and be producing
abnormal chemicals
and there have been now some recent
studies showing that
compared to traditional antidepressant
medication
probiotics do
as well
in many of these studies if you give a
course of probiotic medication but even
more impressive is if you give them a
Mediterranean gut friendly diet you get
actually better results
with more emission than you do with
antidepressant medication
so it's one of the best examples of how
you know feeding your your gut can
actually improve your mood and it's
particularly important because we're
seeing an epidemic of anxiety and
depression
that's partly because of not having many
good gut microbes to start with lots of
junk food diets which make it worse and
of course once you go into that cycle
once you're depressed you're not
thinking about food
the last thing you want to go at and is
you know oh I've got to go and get my
kimchi today you know you just what it's
just fuel so
once you once you understand that you
realize if you want to help someone with
depression you know the first thing is
not to put them straight onto an
antidepressant which in many cases
doesn't work because of this
individuality as we're talking about
which probably again related to the
microbes because they break down the
tablet into its active chemicals but is
to make sure they've actually got gut
friendly
diet and so this is a really exciting
area of research you mentioned them at
attention
the impact that the micro
biome can have on attention that's
really interesting to me because ADHD
has become a very
um
widely discussed
topic
do you think there's a link between ADHD
and the microbiome
highly likely yes I mean there's less
data in it than there is in depression
anxiety the studies are smaller but
those that I've seen all show again a an
abnormality in the gut microbiome of
ADHD kids
and there have been a few studies
showing
that you can reverse it with poo
transplants
which is another area that uh
um
it was quite big a few years ago it it's
not showing the same potential as it as
it did but certainly
affecting attention uh and mood with gut
microbes is definitely on the cards
these studies need to be bigger but
there's certainly preliminary evidence
that what's true for depression anxiety
is also true for this whole spectrum of
other conditions
also you know that have been linked in
the past to diet and you know over sugar
and e-numbers and all these kind of
things so
we've sort of known vaguely there's an
association but I think people haven't
really pinpointed
um the gut microbiome which I think they
should and so absolutely sure that if
you improve the diet of many many of
these kids with ADHD you you would
improve their symptoms and I know
there's some ongoing trials at the
moment it's really been startling over
the last couple of years how um mental
health has really taken center stage in
conversations even conversations on this
podcast most of them we discuss mental
health issues and things like anxiety
and depression as we look around the
world the stats around people that are
being prescribed antidepressant pills
like they're called ssris I believe
um is rising
and I think it's doubled over the last
decade or so with the US kind of leading
the way and then other countries like
China and Japan at the bottom of the
pack
what's your overall view on these these
disorders depression mental health
anxiety
um do you think it stems predominantly
from the microbiome
is that your perspective now from what
you've learned
no I think they're multifactorial so I
think we can't
who can't just blame the gut microbiome
because you do get
these conditions in people who are you
know otherwise healthy
um genetics plays a role you know I'm
going back to my old my old career
um a lot of evidence of strong genetics
in things like depression anxiety but
you can have the tendency to it but you
need to be triggered into it
you need some environmental event and it
could be that once your gut microbes get
in such a bad your gut health is such a
poor State your diet is so bad that
triggers this and you just lack those
chemicals that tip you over into it so
that's why I think
if you if you link these epidemics which
we're going through at the moment
whether it's dementia you know
depression obesity diabetes what are
they all linked for increasing amounts
of ultra processed foods in our diet you
know we're the number one
country in Europe for this rates are
still going up
kids have over 70 percent of their food
is ultra processed now horrendous
adults it's nearly you know between 50
and 60 percent of our of our meals so I
think that effect on the gut microbes
probably just tips this threshold
in people who are susceptible
so it could be that I think that
threshold is going to vary genetically
some people are very resilient some
people are actually uh quite susceptible
and that's my that's my view of it
um which isn't popular because it's
again I make things more complicated
than people like but
you know I think as as a as a scientist
I think most of these diseases are built
up of a different number of risks but
unlike your genetics
you know your gut health is something
you can do something about
and that's what you're doing with Zoe
exactly that's the whole idea behind Zoe
is to empower people to change their
health by
individualizing what they eat that suits
their own metabolism what is Zoe if
someone hasn't heard of Zoe before
Zoe is a
a personalized nutrition company that I
founded nearly six years ago with
uh to my co-founders who came to one of
my uh talks I was talking about the diet
myth and the microbiome and they came up
to me and said you know we think what
you're doing is really exciting we'd
love to talk about getting a company
together to personalize this
and
I I do get people asking me to do
startup companies and I said
I'm not really interested in this we can
spend several million on doing research
first you know I'm not interested in the
usual lifestyle company based on
marketing and I thought I'd never see
them again but they came back two weeks
later said yes we've got several million
we're up and running so I was I was
stuck then I couldn't say no
and basically that we got to go this
massive study called the predict study
which looked at a thousand people mainly
twins gave them these identical meals
gave them these really fancy Tech
glucose monitors with measuring blood
spots with with fat looking at their
microbes logging Foods seeing how
they've gone on for two weeks and use
that data as algorithms to then
predict how they would people respond to
any food
and then we met developed a home test
and launched that initially in the in
the US and uh in the last year the UK
and we've now got 50 000 people have
been this identical home test which is
now a program
that then once you've got your scores
personalized to you you can look up any
food and it gives you a score from
naught to 100
on
what that uh how that food is for you
based on your sugar your glucose blood
sugar profile your fat profile and your
microbiome so it's pushing everyone
to have less sugar Peaks less fat Peaks
and better gut health and so it's
changed you know so in a way that's my
moosli would give me a terrible score my
orange juice would you know a score of
zero
but it's also made subtle changes so you
know I used to eat bananas and now they
they score badly so now I have pairs
instead or apples
um little minor shifts often pushing
people and then you and you have a
virtual nutritionist who helps you plan
your menus to get overall scores that
are pushing you more and more in this
healthy direction so you just start to
understand how what's best for your body
and in a sustainable way and we don't
talk about calories it's like a taboo
word and we're not after crash dieting
or anything else it's like improving
yourself from the inside out
so you and most people
get improved dramatic improvements in
their energy levels which we hadn't even
thought about was the reason but people
started telling us I feel
much better because maybe we're cutting
out all these fat and sugar Peaks that
until the technology came along no one
knew about that were causing these
problems so it's going super well we've
got a still a quarter of a million
people waiting for the product in the UK
on the waiting list and
what's really nice is because we've got
this this commercial arm it allows us to
do these other
um we have the Zoe health study which is
a free app which
um
uh now we're moving that towards
lifestyle like this these fasting AIDS
and things like this we've got a neat
podcast the Zoe nutrition podcast which
is getting the word out about our
science plus blogs and things so you
know it's part of a whole package of
things that we're doing to sort of
educate
people differently and and as I said
make people think about food
in a very different way and I think it's
super exciting because we're you know
we've just raised some more money we've
done some crowdfunding as well which has
gone amazingly well I saw it this
morning
yeah big valuation for a company yes it
is
um and you know I think 200 million
that's a big number
it is and it's but you know I think
we've just
got people's attention exactly the right
time I agree and the technology has just
been exactly right so often it's about
timing yeah I agree I mean I've as I
said before we start recording I've had
two of my guests come here and tell me
about Zoe individually so I think it was
Davina McCall and Gabby Logan who both
mentioned it and then I'd had this email
in my inbox
um from a friend of mine who connected
me to George
and then I started reading about some of
the work that you'd done and saw some of
your videos and that's why I was
compelled to reach out and have you um
on this podcast but the idea of
personalized Health kind of debunks the
long-standing
narrative and myth that there's this one
perfect diet for all of us there's this
one set of foods that we should all be
eating to be healthy and this
personalized approach makes a lot more
sense
um
so I think that's the kind of the moment
in time that you've arrived perfectly in
from a Zoe perspective is this Awakening
to the perspective that personalized
individual diets are
um
The Way Forward yeah and it yeah and of
course covert didn't you know covert was
an amazing time for apps yeah and people
wanting to take
um
control
when they feel they had no control so I
think the idea that you give people an
app and they suddenly are empowered to
do things is a very new idea
particularly in the UK people said no
one over 60 is ever going to do that
they told us it's going to fail and it
it was an incredible success because if
you give people that interaction
that feeling that they are talking to
someone and they're getting information
back and it's a two-way process it's a
completely different idea to the old way
of communicating with people so I think
it is a super exciting time for
for Science and you know we're just
scratched the surface of what we can do
with this personalization because
once we get to a million people you know
the left of detail we can provide back
about
whether you should be eating in the
mornings in the evening you know how
hungry does this make this food make you
feel you know how do you stop you
individually stop getting those sugar
dips how
what combination of foods should you
have you know how do you react to
protein or the you know what do you do
to best sleep well all these things
which people want to know
are going to be possible once we get the
these huge numbers
this is all quite you know it's all we
turn on the I'm gonna have this
conversation with you then I'm gonna
turn on the TV or go on the internet go
on Instagram and all of the
the influences there are going to be
telling me a bunch of stuff a bunch of
fatty diets because they've all got
their own incentives and their own ways
of making money if there was like one
principle I could take away from all of
your work which I know is almost an
impossible to have to do but if there
was one thing just to focus on as I try
and navigate the bombardment of social
media and advertising posts that I'm I'm
gonna be
um on the receiving end of as I leave
this conversation what would that kind
of guiding principle be for me not to
forget
pick changes that are going to last for
life
not as a quick fix I think that's
that's what we're after and that's what
we want to try and instill is this
sustainable healthy way of eating so
that means not not feeling like I'm not
depriving myself and no okay I think
absolutely the the philosophy we have at
Zoe is that nothing is off the table
there's no nothing's banned white
chocolate even white chocolate you can
be the Milky bar kid you know you can
you can have it but realize that you
know it's that rare treat okay and the
more you just and so it doesn't break
everything and you have to you know
start again uh it's about making sure
that the rest of your week is full of
good foods that give you a high score
that can make up for it so we're all
gonna you know
you know the Christmas season everyone
goes crazy and overeats and stuff as
long as you know you've got this
long-term plan that your gut is healthy
and you're working and you're over all
these you're not going to get these
Peaks over time for years that's that's
the goal so absolutely it's about
enjoying food realizing that it's
incredibly important social event it's
why the Mediterranean countries probably
do so much better because it's so much
part of family life and social life in
even in the elderly whether it's with a
glass of wine it's just taking more time
enjoying the novelty of foods and
increasing our range of foods so it's
really broadening it so I really want
everyone to read love food again and and
not have all these Hang-Ups about I
can't have that I can't have this if
you've got enough plants on your plate
basically you know you can eat anything
Tim thank you I feel like it's a good
place to end and I'm really going to go
upstairs and reconsider that vitamin
stack that I have and also
um throughout all those zero calorie
sugar-free drinks that I thought were
good for me
um you've given me a lot to think about
and I'm incredibly honored to have met
you at this time in my life because as I
said it's very relevant to me but also
to have been given the chance to read
your books you've got so many amazing
Books five of them in total I believe
you're working on a new one
um my favorite was these two so the the
spoon fed book and also your most recent
book which is Food For Life which is
basically like a
good glossary of food is that an
accurate statement it goes through all
the key main foods and talks about the
role they play in our health
yes I mean it's been called a food Bible
food
it's a practical guide
to pretty much all the common foods so
you can get what the latest science is
telling you about them all from a
ethical health and environmental
perspective we have a closing tradition
on this podcast where the last guest
asks a question for the next guest not
knowing who they're asking it for
so um
the question that's been left for you
is
you seem nervous yeah I'm very nervous
why do people get people always seem to
get nervous when I ask this question
versus one of my questions ask me any
Science question I don't know well it's
you know
um the question that's been left for you
is
if you could say one thing
to a family member you've lost
who would it be what would you say and
why
well it's got to be to my dad
um
I guess I'd and I'd probably say
I'm really sad we never got to talk
properly
I think you'd be proud of me now
and because as I've explained he died
when I was 21 it's just the time you're
sort of coming out of stewardship you're
becoming more mature at the time you
could start to talk to your parents but
you don't so I feel that's my
um missing part of my life if you like
that um
I never got to discuss
um
anything meaningful with my father
why was that I have that problem too now
have that problem where I struggled to
talk to my
my father
um
I don't know I think
in in hindsight it's it's much easier
thing to say I should have done this
yeah and and I think it could be that
it's built into us that you know we have
a very different relationship to our
with our our fathers that makes it hard
to
to actually talk to them at the same
level or you know not feel some sort of
competition or
critique um so I
I you're actually right that if I was
sat down here with my father
um it would be quite different to
wishing I had done uh all those years
ago and I think it's part of that
grieving process probably
that having lost someone you always feel
somehow responsible you should have done
something before
um I think that's that's part of it and
many people have recurrent dreams also
about
um because my father you know I never
saw him he just I was just told he's
dead
came back from holiday that was it go to
the funeral
and it was a site I
unreal
um
series of events for me and so for years
I used to have these dreams he'd so you
know he'd been in South America and
suddenly appeared again oh so I had to
disappear and um I've come back so that
was an interesting idea going on my
brain that in some ways he wasn't really
dead and um you know I'd get a chance to
talk to him again so it must have been
you know a key part in
the those sub subconscious bits of my
brain
that communication goes both ways though
doesn't it
because
they have to
also be yeah in retrospect he you know
he was very much uh you know
a
1960s dad
uh that you know
um who wasn't really supposed to deal
with children or anything else his he
went to work and studied his study and
because he wasn't sporty never did
anything with with me so absolutely yeah
it's um but as I think you've talked
about before on this podcast you know
children have a very different
perception of that relationship they
feel it's um
it's their fault in a way yeah but uh
yeah he he was not a by modern stance he
wouldn't be seen as a great dad
um
Tim thank you
what a wonderful conversation really
really appreciate your time and thank
you for coming in and sharing your
wisdom with me absolute pleasure
[Music]
quick word from one of our sponsors I've
got a tip for all of you that will make
your virtual meeting experiences I think
10 times better as some of you may know
by now Blue Jeans by Verizon offers
seamless high quality video conferencing
but the reason why I use blue jeans
versus other video conferencing tools is
because of immersion their tools make
you feel more connected to the employees
or customers you're trying to engage
with and now they're launching one of
their biggest feature enhancements to
impact virtual events so far called Blue
Jean Studio I actually used it the other
day I did a virtual event using the
studio which I think about 700 of you
came to TV level production quality all
done by one person with very little
technical experience on a laptop so if
you've got an event coming up and you're
thinking about doing it virtually check
out blue jean studio now let me know
what you think because I genuinely
believe I know this is an advert and I'm
supposed to say this but I genuinely
believe it's the best tool I've seen for
doing really immersive simple but high
quality production virtual events quick
one as you might know crafted are one of
the sponsors of this podcast and crafted
are a jewelry brand and they make really
meaningful pieces of jewelry I think
I've worn this piece for almost a year
it hasn't broken hasn't changed color
because it's really really good quality
and it costs roughly 50 Quid I'm not the
type of person that has Rolexes or
jewelry that cost tens of thousands of
pounds I want pieces that are reliable
that look beautiful and that holds
meaning and significance for me and
that's exactly why I've worn crafted for
so long and when we had the conversation
about them sponsoring this podcast I was
so unbelievably Keen for them to do so
check it out if you're a guy crafted
london.com and yeah if you get any
pieces of crafted tag man let me know
what you think
[Music]
foreign
[Music]